tonight we are doing support calls with
ben
quack quack quack all right say some
stuff now okay uh tonight we're doing
support calls with ben quack quack quack
and you can see me on your streamer now
you captured me i i've captured you like
a a queen
or maybe you might
yeah you captured me like a bow tez
queen come on try to be funnier so i'm
gonna do five zero unrated is that okay
sounds good yeah unless you want to get
farmed for reading you'll say the piece
and then i'll move it because that makes
sense that sounds good
yeah
what you had another suggestion what did
you say
um well if you want to play raided and
then like donate your reading points too
because we're no i don't want to be
charitable but okay no no no
sounds good
okay so
um people challenge me five zero unrated
and that you can play on the stream or
should we make them donate to play me
what'd you usually do
we gotta reward the people who donate
but yeah yeah yeah okay so if you
donated you can challenge me otherwise
you're banned
everybody who's challenging me has
donated i know who these people are so
okay we're gonna play right now
okay can you see the game pop up yeah
we're playing kangaroo
so say something okay pawn
okay
ooh bishop
yeah cara wasn't playing the london
earlier so i'm already very happy
question pawn make it louder with the
slider
make it obs slider louder okay
okay i understand okay i did
am i speaking too softly no probably all
right what'd you say what piece did you
say pawn
night
oh
that's what i assumed you wanted if you
play the london that's what i assumed
um i mean
i don't play this type of london but
no you should start learning it it's
interesting let's do see this is the
problem when you play hand and brain
with ims
i know i'm sorry pawn
terrible
never play f3 come on man
yeah i kind of
thanks dr krieger
all right now matt larson's happy pawn
five months poggers put it in age
karen says it's good now
you guys think the sound is okay i mean
eric's pretty quiet but that's he's just
a quiet person he's the opposite i don't
like yelling pawn he plays good moves
thanks for the 50 pancake gremlin for
the streamlabs charity
all right what move uh pawn
also thanks for the hundred dollars and
eight numbers
thanks for the five hundred dollars from
dom wow wow let's do it thanks dom
god damn what'd you say what piece let's
do night
night
uh i guess you want to go there
that looks nice
remember boys and girls don't castle
don't develop your pieces move the same
knight twice and move all your pawns
especially on the side and always play
off three
right that we're doing everything right
yeah upon the right we're too slow
it's okay please what would you say pawn
okay
man i played c3 now he's po'd
all we have to do is play rook h2 then
r2d2
oh i like that did you get any of that
c3 he's pod yeah i i didn't get the
first one i got the r2d2 though
come on man but now you get the first
one the second one helped you
a little bit
c3po
all right no
uh
let's do
i i'm trying to like internalize your
puns but also this position
it's difficult
the truth hurts yeah let's do
[Music]
oh i have no idea which pawn there i'll
do that one
is that what you meant no
i drew an arrow but not for
g5 wow it was for the other side of the
board but i i thought about that too but
that seemed like a moving im would make
so i couldn't do it
thanks dr krieger okay well we'll do
bishop
i like this though we've so far we've
moved
two minor pieces twice
yeah also
this guy's the slowest player who ever
lived and he has more time than us
thanks for the fifty dollars from
spencer my son gave fifty dollars
now i can go to the movies by myself all
right
nice
i'm gonna uploa update the charity thing
guys let's do tonight
we got we got five thousand already
wow
yeah
we're gonna break a thousand any moment
now
oh you're breaking a thousand yes you're
gonna do 5 000 today also if you stream
like three more hours
there's a good chance yeah
yeah you have to change my goal is 25
000 and you're more popular than me so
yeah yeah but i don't have your special
charm like you're you're good at it it's
special yeah my mom said i was special
after she dropped me on my head
i mean she didn't really drop me it was
more painful he thrusted me on my head
and said jesus christ already yeah
and what's funny is that was a year ago
that's what was funny about it
oh
have you recovered
no all right go eric okay
[Music]
we just lose a pawn we just lost a pawn
me you're the one who said night
yeah we'll do pawn again
yeah the important thing is to say moves
quicker because you know we're too slow
here
that's true but we have to give our
opponent like some hope
right that's true it's hard to give
kangaroo hope all right
yeah uh rook
i have to give kangaroo a lesson because
he bid on on costume stream on chestojo
he did 300
oh wow and he thought he was bidding on
me not giving him a lesson he said he'd
pay anything
so he kept bidding up and up and then
that got the less and he was like oh my
god
that's unfortunate yeah yeah he's pretty
upset about it
maybe he can just cry
like a grand master yeah kangaroo is
like like one of our most aggressive
mods because he's german
so
wait he's a german kangaroo
yes wow he's also ukraine
i can see yeah families like ukraine
yeah
and he speaks every language
russian
german english i think italian et cetera
yeah it's mainly he speaks etc yeah nice
all right kangaroos playing his usual
pace now
yeah i i met a kangaroo in australia but
it didn't speak any languages just kind
of
left around
all right
okay so let's do
queen
all right by the way this is not a joke
we had dinner like 10 of us from karen's
family her brother her other brother
their wives other people wow and the
restaurant had kangaroo and it was
ordered
yeah that's
it's like a delicacy meat from others
yeah it was an expensive restaurant and
the chef is from australia
yeah i'm pretty sure one of the things
you wouldn't expect that octopus too
which is
that's like i mean you shouldn't be
eating kangaroos and octopus
even if you eat meat
i mean those things are smarter than us
let's do bishop
yeah i'm pretty sure australia is the
only country that eats its national
animal
yeah
we don't eat bald eagle here i guess we
don't
not that i know of
okay let's do night
this is a real advertisement for the
london you sack a pawn you get a big
time advantage
yeah it's all about confusing the
opponent let's do bishop
knight
and king
never too late to
castle knight
rook
this position isn't as bad as it is
yeah it could be could be
worse or better yeah
mainly worse queen
wow
[Music]
okay let's do
to take my time here but not too much
time
i'll do queen
uh
to calculate rook
give me a second
i wanted a different rook move i know i
know let's do bishop
i know what you wanted
rook
here we go
oh queen
and then pre-move queen
okay
it says we played 99.9 really
no no no
it says
which one of you is a gm because uh
contact
we're going gonna tell them that you're
putin and you're banned yeah um
[Music]
all right but we have more time at the
end and we made them
so you you took a long think before
playing rook takes e4
did you consider rook g6 there i did
king takes and then queen g5 king h7 and
then rick rick d1 queen e3
king oh king b1
queen h3 maybe it's a little bit murky
i want to play rick d7
but i couldn't because queen e3 check
and whenever my king moves he takes with
check
it doesn't matter where my king moves
takes my bishop with checker my rick
would check that's true yeah and rick g6
i thought didn't work i didn't see rook
d1 but maybe it doesn't
50 bucks this must be philadelphia
thanks bug thing let me refresh
okay i've refreshed